[Music]
the Swiss authorities took him away from
his mother put him in a home and locked
him away at age six Wouter Emma's burger
was placed in foster care with a Parrish
couple who abused him pulled my ears and
my hair a lot and beat me he would lock
me in the basement or in the broom
closet Karla MS burger is still
traumatized by his experiences to this
day he struggles to set foot in a church
the 64 year old set up a small Museum in
the basement of the community center of
his village of fair out Dorf which makes
tangible how the Swiss state condemned
him
around 60,000 people in Switzerland were
submitted to so-called administrative
care by the cantonal authorities because
they were judged to be socially
different the practice continued until
1981 people including his mother were
put in prisons like this one Amos Berger
was born here in 1957 this mining I
suspect that my mother was
administratively cared for because she
was expecting an illegitimate child and
that's what they did at the time they
put such mothers away they didn't fit
into Swiss society that's right stalls
people deemed as being work-shy drinkers
or of having loose morals were taken to
prison without trial two foster families
or to a psychiatric ward there they were
to be re-educated by a system that had
stripped them of their rights and
excluded them from society
historians like auras Garmin confirmed
that these people were not criminals
Garamond conducted research for the
swiss government as part of an
independent commission of inquiry in the
case of those receiving administrative
care it was usually not a matter of
criminal offenses but simply a way of
life that did not conform to social
norms stories like Fattah ms burgers
have cast a shadow over swiss history
there are around 650 prisons and other
institutions in Switzerland in which
children and young adults were
imprisoned exploited and in many cases
severely mistreated ms Berger was locked
up for hours on end at his foster
parents house he was forced to clean and
work in the garden and fields he didn't
accompany us to the house as he suffered
a panic attack when he tried to visit a
few years ago that was so strange he
didn't have boots like an animal I
really felt that this was the end when
he was 11 the parish couple took him to
the psychiatric clinic in min Stirling
and there the boys plight worsened near
the idyllic Lake Constance the hospital
director tested psychiatric medication
on him in the 1960s and 70s all I know
is that I felt a lot of nausea just
generally bad and lousy and every now
and again I'd also have something like a
seizure
the boy does not seem to tolerate
tofranil well and we believe that the
unpleasant symptoms he is showing our
side effects of this medication
[Music]
yeah and it makes my skin crawl and I
ask myself why they did that
ms Berger is fighting to have what
happened to him and others forced into
administrative care publicly recognized
he's received twenty five thousand
francs from a Swiss fund but the canton
of torgul which is jointly responsible
stated that there will be no
compensation the statement acknowledged
the drug trials but said that due to a
lack of further studies the extent of
the damage can't be determined Vata ms
Berger finds these stalling tactics
unbearable tens of thousands of people
have been disenfranchised by the Swiss
state he said and their suffering must
not be forgotten my hope is that
something like this never happens again
and also that this whole dark chapter of
Switzerland's past goes into the history
books right
[Music]